welcome back to the big saturday show as
russia attacks ukraine they're also
detaining wnba star brittany griner on
drug charges russia state media is now
reporting greiner will hold that she
will be held until at least may 19th the
state department finally getting
stronger with their language about her
saying quote we are closely engaged on
this case and in frequent contact with
brittany greiner's legal team we insist
the russian government provide consular
access to all u.s citizen detainees in
russia including those in pre-trial
detention as brittany griner is charlie
i'll go to you first because
right now there's been no diplomatic
access to griner whatsoever and now
we're talking uh the possibility of
another couple of months before anything
happens
yeah this is such a such a deeply
frustrating case uh because when you
look at and and obviously it's not the
only misery that we see in the in the
world today but uh but it but it puts a
face on the misery and when you have an
administration like the bidet
administration that has been so
hapless at every turn uh going back for
for a year or more uh deal and dealing
with russia and dealing with vladimir
putin you just you just cringe to think
at uh how incompetent they are and how
um
it's just so deeply frustrating because
i don't have a whole lot i mean i don't
want to
you know say too much here but i just i
don't have a whole lot of faith i don't
trust these people uh to to negotiate
firmly with with the russians to have a
good outcome here
it's just so worrying tammy um one other
point here i i this caught my attention
an associate professor of journalism at
syracuse university her name is eileen
gallagher she said quote that it's
absurd that this isn't a huge story and
that there's a disconnect here and she
called it quote the exact inverse of the
missing white woman syndrome
being that's a reference to the
criticism on cable news outlets that a
white woman who goes missing gets a lot
more attention than a woman of color
here
what are your thoughts on that you know
it's unfortunate i mean we've got an
environment where everyone's at risk
because of the fecklessness of the biden
administration we have no leverage right
no matter who it was that was taken in
custody we don't know if she had drugs
or not we we should not presume anything
russia says is true uh but so in the
meantime what we do know is what what is
biden gonna say that everybody knows
that if they do say something they won't
hold up on it uh if they do issue a red
line it would be like obama's red line
in syria which he said that's a red line
with the gas don't use the gas and where
that's going to provoke military
response and what do they do they use
gas and nothing happens and then russia
takes crimea so you you've got a dynamic
where for now quite some time with mr
biden that there's nothing that he can
say that anyone is going to take
seriously so regardless of who that was
i think that this is a point where there
are certainly issues here in this
country that we have to deal with when
it comes to society and justice reform
and everything else i agree but my
goodness uh we've got to recognize that
this is a giant problem unfortunately
miss greiner is in the middle of it at
this point it is a worldwide story that
is good news because there are other
people who the hundreds still i think
about 200 americans in afghanistan that
we don't even know who they are and we
and the number of of americans in
ukraine and in russia so at least her
case is
worldly known and we've got to be able
to deal with it uh but again i i like
i'm with charlie there's nothing we have
that can make this go any better
well joe it's actually a delicate
balance there's an espn investigative
reporter who made the point that this
might be on purpose because even her own
family isn't saying too much and the
wnba and the nba have also been advised
by the state department to keep it on
simmer keep it low because if she does
appear to be someone who is that more
valuable they have more incentive to
keep her
we've exhausted every point of leverage
our administration thinks we have to
keep russia from leveling buildings full
of cancer kids and mothers expecting to
have babies and actually some point
what else do they expect us to be
outraged and talk about this story is
getting time on air that's a big deal i
want her to come home but this
administration what point of leverage do
they even have in this moment to get
russia to act on this when we can't get
them to stop killing people can i add on
that point just one once again back to
afghanistan we abandoned hundreds of
people in afghanistan
why russia would think that they should
do anything about one individual uh is
beyond me we created this is an unforced
biden error that we're going to see the
results of the ripples of for years to
come
so frightening and we will we are
thinking of her and hoping for the best
absolutely
yeah hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else